so Peter Luxembourg he seemed very much
as a financial hub but what you're doing
is making sure that people get fiber
very much in their homes exactly
Luxembourg is still a financial help in
Europe but we are going to a
transforming of society where we built
the country into a digital nation and
fiber to the home is is part of that of
that land so we achieved now fifty
percent rollout of fiber to the homes
and I think that's must be one of the
highest levels in EU incredible
incredible I think it's part of a wide
concept an overall plan that you're all
working Joe isn't it exactly so that's
that's a good question we started with
that I think more than a decade ago in
building the next generation of
Luxembourg so known as a financial hub
we use that expertise to become a
digital nation and that goes from from
building all the infrastructure which
which attracts all the companies and you
see nowadays that we have headquarters
like from amazon here itunes and other
companies they are working and living
luxembourg and it's also important that
the people have this all these tools and
this connectivity available at their
homes now a lot of countries in Europe
or not quite as advanced as you are so
give us a tip what does it take to make
it happen a commitment it's a commitment
and absolutely a drive to just say we
have to achieve this in here in
Luxembourg you can see it also on a
government level you have at this
government we have the Prime Minister is
in charge of telecoms and you have the
deputy prime minister who's in charge of
economy who's spreading the message
throughout the world so you have really
the top two ministers in the government
taking up transforming Luxembourg into
this digital nation sounds perfect so
are you sort of laying the groundwork
now are you ready for things like I OT
and 5g that's coming around the corner
how you fix for that well I think we are
quite well prepared if you know that for
example we have a fiber to the home here
with one gig download a 500 megabits
upload I think we can cope with all the
technologies coming up the next couple
of years later thanks very much for
talking to us
I've gone so there you see it looks and
burger shining star in FTTH right across
Europe